some breaking news a rapist who
self-identified as female during
criminal proceedings has been sentenced
at Edinburgh High Court Isla Bryson was
initially reminded but then later
removed from a women's prison after
being found guilty of raping two
vulnerable women between 2016 and 2019
our correspondent Connor Gillis is at
Edinburgh High Court Connor
his crimes these heinous crimes were
carried out by Adam Graham and while
Adam Graham was awaiting trial for both
of these sex attacks he transitioned to
a trans woman known as Isla Bryson
sitting in the dock here at the high
court in Edinburgh today where it
wearing a pink puffer jacket and
eventually Isla Bryson was convicted of
raping two very vulnerable women in
their own homes on the outskirts of
Glasgow a number of years ago now the
judge here said that Isla Bryson sees
themselves as a victim and the judge
said you are not he couldn't have been
cleared about that he said You Prayed on
these women these vulnerable women
raping them in their own homes and he
was clear that Isla Bryson does present
a risk to women now clearly this is a
much bigger case because this has been
at the center of controversy in Scotland
over the course of the last few months
because where Nyla Bryson was initially
convicted they were sent to an
all-female prison at that point and that
triggered a political role a standoff at
holiday just down the road from the
court here in Edinburgh and Nicholas
sturgeon the first minister intervened
at that moment as the political pressure
was brewing as the row was intensifying
and hours later Isla Bryson was removed
from Scotland's only all-female prison
and indeed sent to a man's jail there
was an urgent review at the time
conducted as to exactly how that was
able to happen in the first place and
that review came back within a week or
so and confirmed that newly convicted
transgender inmates will initially be
sent to jails according to their sex at
Birth that was in direct relation
indirect reaction to the Isla Bryson
controversy that was triggered in the
last couple of months now Nicholas
sturgeon we know has had really had
Communications issues when it comes to
some of the big issues that she has
tackled during her Premiership as
Scotland's first Minister but this
certainly was an issue where she
flounder she couldn't answer straight
questions in a way that she has never
been caught out before she had been
asked repeatedly time and again was Isla
Bryson a man was Isla Bryson a woman
given the nature of the crimes that Isla
Bryson was convicted of those rape
charges that they will now spend eight
years behind bars and Nicholas sturgeon
after repeated questioning said that
Isla Bryson almost certainly is claiming
to be transgender as an easy way out now
I asked Nicholas sturgeon when she
resigned at Butte house just a matter of
weeks ago whether the issue around
dialer Bryson whether the issue around
transgender prisoners in Scotland was
one of the reasons that she was leaving
office and she said said absolutely not
short-term issues were not part of her
thinking however her people lining up to
be her successor to replace Nicholas
sturgeon as Scotland's first Minister
have been questioned about this in
recent times as well Hamza Yusuf the
health secretary in Scotland said to Sky
News at the weekend on Sophie Ridge on
Sunday that they thought Isla Bryson the
person here in court today was in Hamza
yusuf's words at it Kate Forbes says
that Isla Bryson is a man as the other
Contender and the third contender in the
race to replace Nicholas sturgeon has
also said that Isla Bryson is a man this
is a case much wider than the criminal
elements it sparked huge conversation
across social Scotland across the whole
of the UK and Isla Bryson will now spend
eight years behind bars in a Men's
prison